last night series finale of Game of
Thrones no official ratings news from
HBO just yet but a report says that over
19 million people watched the final
episode ever but after eight season 73
episodes in over 72 hours of TV spoiler
alert it was not the ending Emilia
Clarke aka the mother of dragons saw
coming thank you to all the people I
don't know allowing us to keep playing
these games and keep telling these
stories Emilia thanked fans and a new
video released today but now we're
learning how tough it was for the
actress to come to terms with Danny's
death what do you think it deserves the
Iron Throne I mean I do are you happy
with how things ended in a just released
New Yorker article called Daenerys tells
all Emilia says that after she read the
final scripts she quote took a very long
walk around London in a day it's not
quite knowing how to digest the news
she also talks about an Oscar night
meeting with Beyonce where they praised
each other but Emilia thought to herself
quote please please like me even though
my character turns into a mass killing
dictator please still think that I'm
representing women in a really fabulous
way and remember that rogue coffee cup
in this season's 4th episode well
eagle-eyed viewers spotted another
mistake last night look right there by
Sam Carly's foot
yep that's a plastic water bottle in
King's Landing meanwhile last night's
finale set the scene for a lot of
potential spin-offs imagine Arya's
adventure Sansa Queen of the north and
Jon Snow beyond the wall that's
speculation but we do know that HBO has
three different G ot shows in
development right now one of them is a
prequel set thousands of years before a
Game of Thrones
Naomi Watts will star and she told us
she's catching up with the original I am
binging it right now and studying it's
very exciting it's very exciting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]